So, what I'm claiming in step two here
is that, if we end up choosing a policy
that is not based on knowing all
of the transitions that there
are still some unknown transitions out
there, but we end up taking a policy
that puts us into a loop where
we never visit any of those,
then that still has to be an optimal
loop, we're not making any mistakes.
It could be that we could do as well
by uncovering those other values but
we can't do any better because
we're assuming in step two
that anything that we don't know
has the largest possible value and
so, if it has the largest
possible value and
we still don't want to go there, then
we're doing at least as well as optimal.
>> Yeah, that's kind of cute.
>> All right, but now,
we need step three.
So now, step three says,
okay, we solve the MDP,
this sort of imagined MDP that has
these optimistic estimates in it,
and let's say that that
actually takes us to a state
action pair that we haven't been
to before, and we learn its value.
Mm-hm.
>> How many mistakes might
we make on route to that?
So, when we actually get to that state,
and
traverse an edge that we didn't know
about, that could have been a mistake.
>> Right.
>> So, that's definitely, one.
And how many mistakes might we make
seeking out the state that actually
turned out to be a really bad state?
>> From a particular state?
I guess, the number of states.
>> Yes, right.
So, the number of transitions that we
might take just to find out that we were
wrong, could be as big as N.
>> N minus one or
something like that but yeah.
>> Yeah, so,
this isn't a deterministic M.B.P.
under to any state our path is
going to be either bounded by N, or
if it's bigger than N, it's infinity
because we're actually looping
it without actually getting
to that other place.
>> Right.
>> So the most it can be is in N right?
>> Mm hm.
>> All right.
So, given that, we might make N mistakes
to find out something new, to learn
something new, to visit a state action
pair that we've never seen before.
How many times can that happen?
How many times can it be that
there's a policy that brings us to
a state action pair that
we haven't been to before?
>> How many times can that be?
>> Yeah, so each time.
This is sort of step three.
Maybe I should write in English.
All right, so what this step three is,
is that what our our max
algorithm tells us to do is to
execute a path that actually brings
us to an unknown state action pair.
Then, we go traverse that edge
find out what it really is and
generate a new policy.
So, the number of steps that it might
take to get to that new state action
pair is N.
>> Right.
>> And the number of times that we might
discover a new state
action pair is what?
>> N times the number of actions.
n times the number of actions because
that's the total number of unknown
things in the graph to begin with.
>> Right.
>> Right, so we're exploring the MDP and
each time we visit state and
take an action we
haven't taken before that's
going to reduce one from the count.
So, the largest that count is
in times K and so, the total
number of mistakes that this algorithm
can make is bounded by N squared K.
>> Hey, that's polynomial.
N, N, and K.
>> It is and
it also doesn't depend on Epsilon, and
it also doesn't depend on Delta.
>> That's even better.
So, wait,
if it doesn't depend on Epsilon, and
it doesn't depend on Delta, then it
means it's polynomial in those things.
>> Sure.
Yes,
it's a very simple
polynomial in those things.
>> So,
then we're polynomial in everything.
Yeah.
Yes, so,
this is an efficient
exploration algorithm for
deterministic MDP's, right.
All it's saying is,
whenever we don't know something,
assume it's awesome and
behave accordingly.
If we learn something new.
Make note of it.
And so, the number of times that we take
a step that might not be the best thing
to do for that state,
it can't be any bigger than N squared K.
>> That's beautiful.
>> Yeah, it's pretty cool, this kind
of analysis comes from a paper that
Koenig wrote with Reed Simmons where
they actually analyzed Q learning in
this kind of setting and they got
a worse bound like N cubed times K.
But this algorithm is sort of pretty
simple, and gives us a nice bound and
it sort of does what you want it to do.
>> It's cool, I will point out that
in cube case, also a polynomial.
>> Yes, yes, but it's a slightly worse
polynomial, you're absolutely right.
I mean, he showed that Q learning has
a polynomial bound in these kinds of
environments.
If you set up the rewards correctly, and
if you set up the initial
value functions correctly.
All right, so, that gets us through
stochastic MDPs that have no state, and
state MDPs that have no stochastic, and
the last thing we want to dive into is,
what happens if we do something like
our max except for on stochastic MDP's.
>> Well, we still have another case,
we have to worry about the case where
we have no state and
we have no stochastic's.
>> Ahh.
So, okay, let's do that one really fast.
>> All right.
So, you're talking about
an environment has one state and
all the actions are deterministic.
They give you a deterministic reward and
return you back to that state.
>> Right.
>> So,
this is essentially
deterministic bandit problem.
>> Right.
>> So, how many mistakes might,
like what would be an algorithm for this
and how many mistakes would it make?
>> The dumbest one, or the simplest one
would just be taking every action once,
and then you know everything.
>> Right, and each of those, so K minus
1 of those are mistakes possibly.
And then,
we only know that we just teach using
the optimal action at their after.
>> Yeah, you could do a little bit
better view assume that everything is
our max because as you come
across our RMX, you ca stop.
>> Very good, yes, right, if you end up
finding along the way, an action that
actually gives you the full value,
the full RMX value, then we don't
have to explore the rest of them because
they're not going to be any better.
Yeah, okay, so that gives us.
It doesn't give us a better bound, but
it does probably give us a better
performance if we keep track of that.
So, yes, so this is a silly case.
[LAUGH]
>> Well, but
it does allow us to say we
solved three of the four.
>> Great.
All right, so
let's dive into number four.